I didn't get a chance to talk to you
about the hateful 8 which is one of my
favorite movies last year I absolutely
loved Quentin Tarantino and I love that
and I don't think I don't think there's
a delicate way for me to say this but
your character just got the [ __ ] kicked
out of her for the entire film almost to
a bizarre comedic I mean it was it was
insane it was crazy and I'm wondering
physically how did you get through that
role it felt like in every single scene
you get hit with a frying pan tossed
into a door hit with some right I mean
oh yeah no the very first day of
shooting I just had a black eye mm-hmm
and I remember just taking a picture of
myself with my phone and sending it to
my mom and saying this is gonna be as
good as it gets like this is the
prettiest thing this is how it starts
with you the black a glamorous moment
yeah we have a picture of you from the
movie and that is you that's again
that's like 10 minutes in yeah and it
just that's a good moment no I like that
some actresses are considered very brave
because they do a role they do something
without makeup you went further than
that and they just had they messed you
up in every conceivable way possible for
the entire yeah and Quentin has his own
blood like they're they literally made a
blood for him they let's stop here and
talk about this see this is what's great
you you forgot you were nervous and now
we're just having a conversation he just
mentioned Quentin has his own blood he
uses what are you talking about Quentin
Tarantino uses his own blood no no no oh
my god no have it Jennifer Jason Leigh
says Quentin Tarantino uses his own
blood in movie scenes well right but go
ahead what is he he makes up a formula
no there's a formula it has a certain
philosophy it has a certain depth of
read right very different than any other
kind of blood and so much of it goes all
over yes in every single movie he does
it is flying everywhere they had to
invent his own blood because it's very
specific and right yeah but I mean when
you're working with Quentin like
whatever he says you just
are so excited to do it because he makes
everything so much fun he was not he was
very concerned because your character
spits in the movie and he said he didn't
want your character to spit like a girl
he wanted you to spit in a specific way
what was he talking about well he said
like spit for me and I I did and he said
yeah that's like a girl so what you what
he wanted was a Sid Vicious spit so he
wanted it like a like a dart like you're
real is 'red can you do that shitty no
oh if I spit it's like that's how I spit
like a girl thank you that's the
fifty-fifth thing I do like a girl but
but no whenever I've been doing
something I like jogging or something
and tried to spit or I ride my bike a
lot and every now and then I'm like I
got a spit I spit it just goes all over
myself
yeah so I need training from Quentin
Tarantino he needs to train you I never
spit it's just not something you know
when she would doing yeah why would you
but I learned I did learn for the that
you've learned all kinds of skills you
know did we have spit lessons yeah
you